the game we've all been waiting for
no I'm not talking about days gone zelda
or for honor I'm talking about Skyrim
remastered or his Bethesda's calling it
the elderscrolls v Skyrim special
edition along with improved graphics and
better performance it will also offer
mod support here the top six mods we
want to come to consoles what's a map
without roads for some reason Skyrim is
vanilla map doesn't have them this seems
like a huge oversight fortunately as
you'd expect a moderate fix this ice
Pangolin walked every single road in
Skyrim to provide us with a useful map
thank God nothing says immersion quite
like starving to death in the freezing
cold while trying to start a fire with a
toothpick and a pebble frost fall a
survival mod tracks temperature time of
day location and the clothes on your
back in order to determine a current
condition if that's not immersive enough
this mod plays nicely with realistic
needs and diseases with this mod you'll
need to eat drink sleep and basically
take care of yourself also you might
want to lay off the mead with this mod
because if you drink too much there's a
good chance you'll Biff it with these
two mods you'll experience Skyrim in a
very different and deadly way now let's
talk about magic magic and Skyrim is
already pretty sweet but there's
definitely some room for improvement and
that's exactly what apocalypse does
overall this mod adds 155 new lore
friendly spells one of which lets you
see the world through the eyes of NPCs
enemies and of course animals these
spells range from restoration
destruction illusion alteration and
conjuration mages will be in heaven with
this mod
obviously the weapon mod most of us want
our lightsabers but let's stick to lore
friendly mods for now immersive weapons
and armor are two separate mods that add
dozens if not hundreds of new weapons
and armor sets these can range from new
iron and steel sets to dragon and glass
sets the armor mod will also give you
access to some sweet capes and cloaks
when coming up with this list we wanted
to avoid UI modifications and changes
but we made an exception with Sky UI it
may not be the sexiest or most exciting
mod but it can make a world of
difference this mod completely reworks
the inventory management making it
easier to find important items and sort
through all the junk you'll inevitably
hoard honestly I can't imagine playing
Skyrim without this mod and if Bethesda
doesn't introduce a new UI this will
probably be the first one I download as
great as all these mods are false car
takes the sweet roll you may have heard
of this one already but if not it
basically adds a new lore friendly quest
line that takes place in a whole new
area this area is roughly the size of
two to three holds there are 26 quests
the characters are all fully voiced and
the fan-made expansion offers a brand
new soundtrack Alexander velikiy and 19
spent over 2000 hours making this mod
with the game's creation kit if that's
not enough for you hopefully moon path
to elsewhere will make its way to
consoles as well this mods a bit more
linear than false car but it packs some
interesting locations and new characters
all of which are fully voiced with
accents to match those are just a few
mods we'd like to see in Skyrim special
edition but I want to know what mods you
want to see in the remaster let me know
in the comments below and if you liked
this video make sure to LIKE and
subscribe down below until next time